"THE FIVE" ."
♪ ♪
>> Dana: THE WAR ON MEAT,
PLASTIC STRAW MAN, THESE ARE THE
EXTREME 2020 IDEAS DEMOCRATS ARE
PROPOSING.
CHECK OUT SOME OF THEIR OLD
STATEMENTS.
SPEAK OF THIS U.N. REPORT, 11
YEARS THAT WE HAVE LEFT.
>> DO YOU BAN PLASTIC STRAWS?
>> I THINK YOU SHOULD, YEAH.
>> PEOPLE SAY WE ARE GOING TO BE
OKAY IF THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
POPULATION WAS VEGETARIAN
IMMEDIATELY.
>> THIS IS ON PAR WITH
WORLD WAR II.
>> Dana: BUT THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL MOMENT OF THE
NIGHT COMING FROM BERNIE SANDERS
WITH THIS ANSWER ABOUT CUTTING
GLOBAL POPULATION GROWTH TO
FIGHT GLOBAL WARMING.
>> IN MEXICO CITY AGREEMENT
WHICH HE DENIES AID TO THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE WORLD
THAT ALLOW WOMEN TO HAVE
ABORTIONS OR EVEN GET INVOLVED
IN BIRTH CONTROL, TO ME, IS A
TOTALLY ABSURD.
I THINK ESPECIALLY IN POOR
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD,
WHERE WOMEN DO NOT NECESSARILY
WANT TO HAVE LARGE NUMBERS OF
BABIES, AND WHERE THEY CAN HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY THROUGH BIRTH
CONTROL TO CONTROL THE NUMBER OF
KIDS THEY HAVE.
SOMETHING I VERY, VERY STRONGLY
SUPPORTED.
>> Dana: LET ME PHRASE THE
QUESTION HE GOT FROM THE
AUDIENCE.
THE PLANET CANNOT SUSTAIN THIS
GROWTH, TALKING ABOUT HUMAN
POPULATION.
I REALIZE THIS IS A POISONOUS
TOPIC FOR POLITICIANS BUT IT'S
CRUCIAL TO FACE.
EMPOWERING WOMEN AND EDUCATING
EVERYONE ON THE NEED TO CURB
POPULATION GROWTH SEEMS
REASONABLE.
SHE ASKS IF ANYONE WOULD BE
COURAGEOUS ENOUGH TO SAY SO.
BERNIE SANDERS SAID WHAT HE
THOUGHT.
JESSE?
>> Jesse: AMAZINGLY STUPID.
THANK YOU TO CNN FOR THIS
CONTENT THAT WE WILL MOCK.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK CNN
FOR ASKING SOME OF THESE FRONT
RUNNER SPECIFIC QUESTIONS WHICH
THEY ACTUALLY ANSWERED.
FOR INSTANCE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BAN THE COMBUSTION ENGINE?
YES.
NATURAL GAS DRILLING?
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BAN COAL?
YES.
GOODBYE PENNSYLVANIA, GOODBYE
MICHIGAN, GOODBYE OHIO.
BUT IT GOES, GETS BETTER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BAN OFFSHORE
DRILLING?
YES.
GOODBYE FLORIDA, GOODBYE ANY
CHANCE YOU WILL EVER HAVE.
BUT IT DOES GET BETTER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BAN FACTORY
FARMING?
YES.
GOODBYE IOWA, GOODBYE WISCONSIN.
THE ANSWERS WERE STUPID AND THE
QUESTIONS WERE AMAZING FOR
REPUBLICANS, AND EVERYONE SHOULD
THANK CNN.
THE FACT THAT THEY ACTUALLY GOT
ON THERE AND SAID DEPOPULATION
CONTROL IS CRAZY.
THAT IS WHAT THEY DO IN
COMMUNIST CHINA.
IT'S A DISCREDITED THEORY.
IN FACT, THE SHOOTER IN THE LAST
TWO MASS SHOOTINGS, HE HAS
ASCRIBED TO THAT PHILOSOPHY.
NOW THEY ARE ALSO SAYING WE
SHOULD START EATING LESS MEAT.
GET OUT OF MY KITCHEN.
WHAT IS THIS?
GET OFF OF MY RANCH.
ALL OF THESE IDEAS ARE JUST
GOING TO MAKE EVERYONE'S LIVES
MISERABLE.
THEY ARE GOING TO COST TRILLIONS
OF DOLLARS, AND THEY ARE NOT
GOING TO CHANGE THE EARTH'S
TEMPERATURE 1 DEGREE.
>> Dana: THAT IS A VERY GOOD
POINT AND IF YOU TAKE ALL THE
THINGS THEY TALKED ABOUT, MOST
OF THE THINGS WOULD ACTUALLY
INCREASE IN EMISSIONS OF
GREENHOUSE GASES, INCLUDING IF
YOU WANT TO DO AWAY WITH
NUCLEAR.
YOU WERE SHAKING THEIR HEADS AT
THE BERNIE SANDERS LINE.
>> OF COURSE BERNIE IS GOING TO
TAKE THIS QUESTION, I WILL SAY
IT!
COME ON, WE WANT TO HELP YOU
KILL YOUR CHILDREN.
IT'S CRAZY.
SEVEN HOURS OF THIS ON CNN?
SEVEN HOURS?
IT'S LIKE CNN IS A RESTAURANT
THAT THE MAFIA BOUGHT AND THEY
ARE BURNING IT DOWN FOR THE
INSURANCE MONEY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THEIR RATINGS
WERE LIKE.
THE FUTURE SEEMS SO BLEAK.
COULD IT SOUND ANY WORSE?
WE ALL NEED TO BE VEGETARIANS
LIVING LIKE IT'S WORLD WAR II,
DRINKING OUT OF STRAWS THAT
DON'T WORK.
GIVE ME TRUMP EVERY DAY OF THE
WEEK.
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN.
I DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN THIS
BLEAK -- IT'S LIKE
"THE HUNGER GAMES."
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO HEAR
ABOUT THE HURRICANE CONNECTION?
>> Juan: I WANT TO COMMENT ON
THE WHOLE THING BECAUSE I FIND
THIS SUCH A DISTORTION.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THE THINGS JESSE
SAYS LIKE THEY ARE ATTRIBUTED
THEY DIDN'T SAY THESE THINGS.
THEN MICHAEL SAYS, OH, KILL
BABIES.
NOBODY SAID ANYTHING LIKE THAT!
>> Jesse: HE SAYS HE WANTS TO
BAN THE COMBUSTION ENGINE AND
ELIMINATE COAL-FIRED POWER
PLANTS.
>> Juan: HERE IS THE HEART OF
THE RESPONSE COMING FROM THIS
TABLE, THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
CONTROL YOU, THEY WANT TO TAKE
AWAY YOUR STRAWS!
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO EAT MEAT!
OH, MY GOSH.
TO ME, IT'S MIND-BOGGLING.
ONE, DEMOCRATS HAVE IDEAS.
A BOY, REPUBLICANS HAVE NO IDEAS
WHEN IT COMES TO DEALING WITH
CLIMATE CONTROL.
SO REPUBLICANS SAY, THAT IDEA IS
RIDICULOUS!
DEMOCRATS SAY, LET'S TALK ABOUT
THIS.
GUESS WHAT, OVERWHELMINGLY, 80%
PLUS OF DEMOCRATS AND 60% OF
INDEPENDENTS SAY CLIMATE CHANGE
IS A BIG ISSUE.
WE WANT TO DEAL WITH IT.
IT'S AN EMERGENCY.
SO HERE ARE SOME OF THESE IDEAS.
NONE OF THESE IDEAS ARE RADICAL,
BY THE WAY.
>> Jesse: BANNING FACTORY
FARMING IS NOT RADICAL?
>> Juan: YOU WOULD BE
SURPRISED AT HOW MANY FARMERS
SAY THAT FACTORY FARMING IS NOT
EFFICIENT.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN SAYS HE
WANTS TO GET RID OF EVERY
SINGLE --
>> Juan: YOU CAN SHOUT AND
KEEP TALKING OVER ME --
YOU JUST TALK, TALK, TALK.
KEEP TALKING BUT GO TALK TO
FARMERS, AND THEY SAY THEY
PREFER THERE WOULD BE LESS OF
THAT FACTOR, BIG CORPORATE
FARMING.
>> Jedediah: YOU THINK ALL THE
THINGS JESSE SAID SOUNDED CRAZY,
HE REPEATED ALL THE THINGS THEY
SAID.
BAN PLASTIC STRAWS --
>> Juan: WHAT IS SO RADICAL
ABOUT BLANDING PLASTIC STRAWS?
>> Jedediah: HE'S TALKING
ABOUT AMERICAN TAXPAYER ABORTION
NOT ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES
BUT ELSEWHERE.
>> Juan: IT IS ILLEGAL UNDER
THE MEXICO CITY AGREEMENT.
WHAT YOU GET HIS DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT, I'M GOING BACK HERE
TO CLINTON AND OBAMA BOTH SAID
NO TO IT.
IT'S NOT A NEW IDEA.
BUSH PUT IT BACK, BUT IT'S NEVER
BEEN ABOUT ABORTION.
IT'S ABOUT BIRTH CONTROL.
>> YOU DON'T THINK TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, Y
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, U
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, D
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, N
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, T
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, I
PEOPLE TO CONVERT TO VEGANISM, K
BRINGING UP ABORTION IN A
CONVERSATION ABOUT POPULATION
CONTROL OR BANNING FRACKING AND
PLASTIC STRAWS.
NONE OF THIS SOUNDS EXTREME TO
YOU AT ALL?
>> Juan: HE DIDN'T BRING UP
ABORTION, HE BROUGHT UP BIRTH
CONTROL.
>> Jedediah: YOU ARE THE
AUDIENCE FOR THIS.
THERE IS AN AUDIENCE FOR THIS.
>> Juan: HUGE!
YES!
>> Jedediah: RIGHT NOW, IT'S
SOUNDING SO EXTREME.
>> Juan: I'M NOT EXTREME.
IT'S NOT EXTREME.
>> Jedediah: IT DOESN'T SOUND
EXTREME TO A LOT OF THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S SCARY.
>> Jesse: DO YOU THINK BANNING
THE INTERNAL COMBUSTION ENGINE
IS A RADICAL IDEA?
>> Juan: YEAH.
>> Jesse: THAT IS WHAT
JOE BIDEN JUST SAID!
HE SAID HE WANTS TO ELIMINATE IT
IN HIS FIRST TERM!
>> Juan: THIS IS SO OBVIOUS, I
DON'T -- WHAT HE WANTS TO DO IS
HAVE LESS RELIANCE.
IN OTHER WORDS, GO TOWARDS --
THE IDEA THAT YOU WANT TO HAVE A
REAL DISCUSSION ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS SCARY TO YOU BECAUSE
IT SHOWS YOU HAVE NO IDEAS.
I HEARD YOU SAY FLORIDA, OH,
FLORIDA'S GONE.